depuis le départ des russes les rues de
borodianka sonde à peine reconnaissable
un spectacle de désolation auquel
assistent les habitants hagards certains
sortent de chez eux pour la première
fois depuis la fin des bombardements
dans ce quartier tout ou presque a été
détruit
les survivants découvre des corps sans
vie abandonné au coin des rues beaucoup
redoutent un scénario identique à celui
de butch à une autre ville martyre en
périphérie de kiev
d'autres personnes sont sous les ruines
il y à ce bâtiment près du bureau des
impôts dans le centre ville deux
sections ont été complètement détruites
là si vous pouvez le voir c'est là il y
a encore des gens sous les ruines
certains immeubles menacent de
s'effondrer des équipes de déminage sont
encore attendues abordé en cas ici le
bilan des pertes humaines n'est pas
encore connue mais le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky a averti
que les russes aient serré de cacher les
traces de leurs crimes
des informations indiquent déjà que le
nombre de victimes des occupants
pourraient être encore plus élevé à bord
audience car les occupants ont commis
des actes que les habitants n'avaient
jamais vu même pendant l'occupation
nazie il ya 80 ans vicitmes 17 ton
depuis que les ukrainiens ont repris les
villes autour de la capitale kiev au
moins 400 corps de civils ont été
retrouvés